Salam alaikum peace be with you thank
you for tuning in for another episode of
the Deen show we're here every week same
time same channel we have another
exciting story for you of someone who
lived that life of debauchery a life
that doesn't bring peace and happiness
if you've been wanting to know the
purpose of life why you've been created
if you've been wanting to know is there
more to life than just chasing that man
or woman the money the material things
things that don't bring peace and
happiness are you disrespectful to your
parents and are you not given the rights
that others have upon you then you want
to tune in for this show because if you
have that void inside and you've been
taking xanax and you've been filling it
with drugs and alcohol and all these
other things and it's not going away
this guest of ours he was having a void
and he was living a life that many of
you out there are living today that's
not bringing you peace and happiness so
we want to benefit from his story that's
why we brought him on Diego here on the
Dean show we'll be right back with his
wonderful story don't go anywhere
welcome back to the D show we got da go
in the house peace be with you saw
Michael alaikum Salaam
how you doing Diego LA I'm Dylan my
Latino brother yes do habla espanol
si that's a silly question ask someone
who's native but know there's some
Spanish that don't speak Spanish se all
right Amir born here but you were born
in America I was born in America my
family's from Ecuador for Ecuador yes
and you've still kept with the language
you still speak it in your house you
speak it yes and hamdullah
we that's the first language Spanish and
we speak it at home to our parents and
hamdullah that's we try to keep that we
definitely don't want to let that go and
we try to pass it on to our children as
well yeah so the people heard me
mentioned when I opened the show they I
mentioned what is predominant with many
of the youth even adults nightclubs
partying you know trying to get to a
level of prestige with money so you can
have a nicer car nicer suit nicer dress
to go out with get the attention from
the boys from the ladies and the boys
just going around looking for the girls
they're on the hunt
so not really respecting the parents
disobeying the parents just living a
life of desires so there are many
parents tuning in and they're like yeah
my son my daughter they're out of
control
alright you were out of control actually
I was to a certain extent I preferred my
friends over my family my mom would like
to have family gatherings or you know
wanted us to be
you know more in tuned with family but I
preferred you know paying all my friends
whenever they had some to do I would
choose them if I gave my family time
would it be very short and that's the
type of lifestyle that I that I enjoy
the parties you know hanging out with
with friends with fat with women the the
clubs and everything that comes along
with that
and just basically wasting wasting time
I found myself times where you know just
hanging out outside not doing anything
in the cold just because I wanted to be
outside so it was a little bit more you
hanging out in the cold just to be you
know just a group of friends just
hanging out less in the park or you know
just obviously just not doing anything
and just because I did not want to be at
home just because I didn't want to be
with my family and just because I wanted
it I preferred my friends over them
which it was very unfortunate you know
but that's the that's what I was caught
up in where people always trying to fit
in and trying to do whatever you know
monkey trick it took to kind of fit in
to be like with the cool people dog
sniff around definitely we used to have
little clubs in high school and then
even before that where you had to do
certain things you know you had to dress
a certain way you had to look a certain
way you had to act with with the women
or the girls in certain ways in order to
be part of that quote unquote cool group
and then everyone else was put on the
side so you had the popular kids and
then everyone else so where did you
fidei I tried to fit in with with the
popular kids I you know so I did find
myself in that in that circle and even
when I went to high school when my
brother was there he was already a
junior and senior when I joined and I
wanted to be with with them not with my
brother so every time I saw my brother
in school I kind of shied away because
he was a you know almost finishing he
was you know part of the intelligent
group and I was I wanted to be with with
with the popular kids now your family
you came from a background of
Catholicism yes we're your parents
practicing the religion my parents were
my mom was very
she was very religious she always
believed in God and you know she was the
one who took us to church on every
Sunday and kind of you know advised us
you know to do the same as far as
religion and to believe in God but as
far as what I would I felt and what I my
heart wasn't really attached to religion
in that way my my take on it was if I do
something wrong I run to the church I'll
light up a candle
I'll pray a few Hail Marys a few our
fathers and I'll feel like a new man
once I step out and because of that I
felt like I can do anything else that
anything that I wanted and I usually
kind of steered it back into the wrong
direction
but all I had to do was run back to the
church and do the same so it wasn't
something that I was really feeling it
was just kind of acting and you know
nothing really came from the heart what
why do you think so many people are
drawn to doing what you are doing just
to hanging out with the homeboys you
know chasing the girls going to the
house parties or the nightclubs you kind
of graduate right you can't get into the
nightclub because you need to be 21
right but that's sort of people have
house parties right based as they get
the pegs right so did you have some of
those why do people why are people drawn
to that it's an easy lifestyle it's fun
quote/unquote fun for for the time a lot
of people say that you want to you know
live your life to the fullest and I used
to be the ones who host the parties I
used to host some parties you were like
the promoter yeah and like you know
because of that that group that I was in
you know have the parties at the house
and that was kind of you know was there
a cover charge did you make somebody
sometimes sometimes we charged other
times you know we just invited people
just let me say so I know Diego and yeah
I'm in free you know it was a small
basement but we crammed a lot of people
in then you know felt like the man now
you dealing the party right well you're
like Donnie Brasco or you know Tony
Montana are you four
so that's a kind of relationship and
that's kind of feeling that you want to
have you know you go back to school the
next weekend the next week and you have
a sense of you know oh that was a cool
party and that's what talk talking
they're giving you exactly that
attention is what I what I wanted and
but at times it was very limited you
know so every time it kind of feeds down
you want to do something else to bring
it to bring it back up you're
identifying with a lot of the youth now
that are watching this or people have
been there done that some people still
in the same ship that's sinking that's a
sinking ship of course isn't it you got
drugs no good for you at the bottom line
at the end of the line you keep doing
drugs you're gonna be a failure Yeah
right
we keep drinking alcohol you're gonna be
a failure you keep chasing your lessons
that you're gonna be a failure so that
that's a loser lifestyle but many people
let tuning in they're connecting because
they're maybe parents or their friends
they're talking about live the purpose
of light of the crater's told you to
live fulfill that live that you'll have
peace you'll be successful when you die
you'll get paradise they're not hearing
it but now they're identifying with you
they're like why did he leave that you
know he was like a popular guy he was
doing the things that I want to do but
were you happy actually I wasn't I made
my family sad in numerous occasions I
find my I find my I found myself excuse
me um kind of you know just trying to
fit in and even because of that fitting
in I found myself in the hospital
numerous of times I had alcohol
poisoning just because I wanted to fit
in I got arrested numerous occasions
just because I wanted to be the one that
people came to there was a time in high
school where you know I was with a group
of friends and just because I had the
car or the car that my brother lend me
and I want to drive everybody around and
be the one to cut class and not go to
school I got arrested with a whole bunch
of other kids and you know you know I I
mean my parents said you know kinda
disappointed them and that happened in
numerous occasions which you know after
you know after a certain time you know
it's not it's not a cool life to live
it's not it's not really you know
something that you can benefit from so
you guys are just riding around cruisin
for a bruisin well you got 12 15s in the
back and you're booming a base and yeah
everybody just like a zombie
boom bobbing their heads nonsense is a
no purpose yeah absolutely no purpose
it's like driving to something just go
into one place from one place to another
no ma'am but where you going we're just
not at all blind driving blind that's a
good example now driving blind that many
people are driving blind we care that's
what we're sharing your story with the
world we'll be right back with Diego and
why he is living the purpose of life
that's from the crater and it brings
peace joy and happiness the rest of his
story when we come back here on the Dean
show let's see what everyone's talking
about
but the argument here is that God out of
his love because in all honesty if you
really wanted to do something you're
gonna find the way where there's the
world there's a way absolutely excellent
there are a few problems here why were
people of generations and generations
and generations being told to worship
one God asked that God for forgiveness
ask him for for salvation seek his mercy
no one else's so he picked up the crime
which is the last
I was 16 years eight years in active
reservist and eight years active dude
but the bottom line is that I'm an
ophthalmologist I'm a specialist in
cataract & refractive surgery I'm the
medical director of the major eyes these
are not God God is the one who created
everything in his universe that's the
one I'm gonna worship and prostrate to
how can you go wrong doing that don't
believe it on yours out of his longing I
mean top ten reasons why Jesus cannot be
God let's get right to it not be God
number ten number ten back here on the
Dean show with Diego and you had a
wonderful story to tell like many of the
people that are out there they're living
a fantasy in their head that make the CD
of the newest pop star that came out
throw it in the car and they're booming
the system and now maybe they got you
know the girls in the back and guys in
the front of both mixed in they're just
cruising car accidents you had a car
accident that actually at that point now
one point that you you almost died right
actually yeah unfortunately you know I
when I was in the whole party is still
in the party scene and still trying to
blend in and not necessarily blend in
for the popularity of it but more
because I was already into that
lifestyle and one time he I said I did
go to a party and there was drinking
involved and I was supposed to go to a
different event another party per se but
I had to go drop someone off which was
about maybe 15 20 miles from who I
needed to go so once I did that once I
dropped off this person and was going it
was on my way I kind of woke up and I
woke up outside of my car and I was
looking into the looking onto my car and
it was already damaged the whole driver
side was a so now you got a car accident
I got into a car accident but I didn't
know I drove about maybe like five miles
unconscious I didn't know what was going
on
I woke up with a car already smashed the
drivers the drivers side completely you
know basically cement in and a lot of
people said you know how how did I
survive I was looking with a whole bunch
of people on the sidewalk and I even
asked the individual next to me I said
what happened he said you've got into a
car accident and for me for me it didn't
happen I didn't realize it I didn't feel
it and I felt like you know Allah took
me out of that situation without harming
me but I did obviously get in trouble
with the law again and at that point my
brother came to me and said we have to
make a change and we have to do
something that is going to allow us to
get closer to Allah and better our
relationship with Allah and create
something that you know we get away from
this because it wasn't helping us it
wasn't benefiting me it at that point
see my family kind of cut down but still
supportive I'm glad they never pushed me
away they were always supportive and
that was something that you know these
these people my parents were giving me
so much support and love but I'm over
here doing these things to disobey them
and kind of leave them on the side and
when it wasn't benefiting anyone so at
what point now did you realize okay I
got to start living the true purpose of
why I've been created this lifestyle is
getting played out it's getting tired
yes okay so at what point did you accept
this way of life how did you conclude
that okay this is not just another
religion is not a man-made religion it's
not an organized religion organized by
man or men it's the way of life from the
Creator providing proof evidences beyond
a shadow of a doubt that it is from the
Creator and now I need to submit to what
God wants me to do I need to obey Him
because Hellfires true paradise is true
and at the end we're going to be judged
on a day of judgment and if I lived this
you know debauchery lifestyle hedonistic
lifestyle just chasing the boys and
getting their attention instead of the
detention of the Creator if I just keep
submitting to my desires I've got a good
chance I'm gonna end up definitely in
the Hellfire but if I do good live good
I'm gonna have peace tranquility life
and I'll have paradise what at what
point did you realize this is the truth
and I want to get to paradise
right my brother accepted Islam first he
was a most of personal family to accept
Islam and I always knew that there was
something with my relationship with the
religion like I mentioned before going
to church and and just trying to pray I
knew there was something someone out
there that I had to turn to
it wasn't my parents it wasn't the
priest I had to turn to someone and when
my brother accepted Islam I said that it
wasn't for me I didn't want to leave the
lifestyle and but I knew that there was
something missing in my life
so I asked ask God or whoever was up
there to if this is right for me and
this is something that's going to
benefit me something good for me too
please just place it in my heart because
I wasn't able to decide on my own my
desires were too great I didn't want to
leave them off and so the next morning
or couple days later I kind of woke up
with this desire of wanting to accept
Islam because it was clear I had friends
who were already in studied it yeah had
friends who were Muslim I had friends
who told me about Islam and all these
things that you know when my brother
would go and ask questions I would be
with him he would answer some questions
as well because he was already learning
so everything made sense as far as the
Creator was it something like story book
story tales Santa Claus down a chimney
like the fairy dust fairy tales and
stuff that just like bizarre or what
when you're asked when when the truth is
presented to you was it something that's
lucid it's clear it's not like this
hocus-pocus stuff right it was
definitely clear yeah it definitely made
sense because of you know when you turn
to allah when you turn to to god you
have a a purpose you have a reason you
don't have to turn to a man to a woman
to your parents to your brother you're
turning to the creator and you're having
a really and you build a relationship
directly with him and so all of that
makes sense to me the statues the idols
the the angels of believing or
worshipping them didn't make sense to me
so everything had clear evidence the
quran had evidence all the all the
questions had answers to them and
everything makes sense everything was
clear and to know that Allah is merciful
and to know that Allah you know will
forgive you as long as you do what
you need to do as long as you turn back
to him as long as you if you do
something wrong or if you do have this
type of lifestyle but you return to him
and you worship Him the way he should be
worshipped it doesn't matter how high
your sins are it doesn't matter what
kind of or how low you think you are you
turn back to Allah and Allah will
forgive you and continue to to helping
so all of that makes sense to me and was
it good he's the most loving the most
kind Allah is the one who's the most
merciful that he forgives all sins
definite long as we come to him was to
see her heart he doesn't look at your
color shape size that's what he looks at
your heart so your heart was yearning
for the crater you called upon him he
facilitated the way yes so call right
now call Carlos 1-866 to Islam call now
call on the Creator alone not his
creation not to a saint not to Jesus not
to anything that's created but to the
one create or that's what you did let me
digress a little bit and talk to our
sisters and humanity and sisters in the
deen many who are seeking not the
attention of the Creator but the
attention of the boys they want to wear
the tightest clothes you know the tawdry
is outfits and at the end you know the
boys will sing them sweet nothings in
their ear and lullabies and at the end
they end up getting used and abused they
end up getting taken for a ride
is this something because you were there
how do men view women what do they want
from a woman so we can help save the
woman from being in a catastrophe
respond Allah you know this is an
unfortunate thing but I'm able to
appreciate it because in the in the past
that's how I was I looked at women as
just a figure I didn't care too much
about how they what they had inside of
them or you know how they thought it was
just something physical pure physical
and Allah created us in a way that you
know men and women are tight are tried
to each other that's normal but it's
just how we go about it and what we do
in order to get together is the way that
needs to be controlled
unfortunately now you find kids you'll
find youth teens boys and girls just
mixing with in with one another just
because they see things on TV they hear
things on a radio and the music and
just coming together trying to mix and
trying to live that lifestyle I find
where I live in New Jersey girls young
girls dressing in in basically in short
clothing very provocative very
provocative but when they're walking by
an adult or something like something
like this they try to cover themselves
why because by nature they feel a little
bit uncomfortable but then when in front
of the boys you know they don't mind
they think of something cool something
cute but then they find themselves in
difficult situations maybe getting with
the getting together with a boy that
doesn't really care he doesn't care
about she doesn't care at all and then
leaves them off and now these these
girls they end up pregnant 11 years old
get pregnant 13 years old pregnant and
but he said no but he said he loves you
so he said yeah is that a lie for the
most part it is most part he'll say a
boy will say anything anything to get
closer to the girl to get what he wants
exactly and that's unfortunate because
at the same time the boys are taught
that yeah you know so it's kind of and
then then he's got bragging rights now
you know he's using your name maybe
writing it in the bathroom stall or
something right you pissed them off now
put your phone number I had heard this
this kind of crazy stuff was going on
definitely definitely I mean it happen
in the past and it's happening more so
now and unfortunately when the girl that
repetition of the young girl and that
was ruined but the repetition of the boy
is on a high status now he's he's a more
the popular one in school and it's a you
know it's not a fair trade yeah so this
is the protection Islam is the best self
defense to protect the woman protect the
man protect us from all the evil that's
out there calling you to everything pure
organic good and we'll be right back
with more to talk about how you're more
respectful to your parents you're
married you respect the woman more you
respect yourself more you're happy you
got peace
we'll be right back with Diego here in a
Dean show I don't see him here in John
now Allah opens a window so he can see
his friend in hell he looks at his
friend doesn't it
you okay can I pull you out he doesn't
say that I said man you almost took me
to the party with you you're the one who
used to crack jokes with me about
religion know that you are that guy and
then now imagine this guy who's in
Jannah looking at this and saying oh
thank God I didn't listen to you because
for a second there I was think
about it he just saw Hellfire she comes
back into Jannah and it's like he just
got here for the first time the words in
the Quran are amazing of a man a
community are we not gonna die anymore
really
oh wait you already knew that he's a
juggler but when he saw a glimpse of
Hellfire the most beautiful thing you
could appreciate about Jenna first and
for like it's a reintroduction to Jenna
what's the first thing he says I'm not
gonna be tortured there's no more pain
that's the second thing he appreciates
why because he just saw what Kane looks
like back here on the Dean show with
Diego and we're reaching out to the
whole of humanity people who are
watching us international over the globe
and parents are sitting watching tight
because they see that their daughter is
drifting off and you know what we want
the best for everybody so we're giving
them the inside scoop from someone who
was in the scoop who was there been
there done that
al hamdulillah all praises to the crazy
that happens there who guided you yes
your parents are they happy with you
they've even accepted Islam yes my I
said my brother said but Islam first and
it trickled down to myself my mom after
a couple years and then just recently my
father which makes it really nice you
know the family now were able to
interact with each other with a purpose
with religion with God and it kind of
makes things you know a lot smoother
granted we're not the perfect family we
still have our little arguments and
things like that but at least we know
who to turn back to at least we know our
purpose and how we need to be with each
other so how did they end up wait who
else in your family accepted Islam my
brother my here my mother and my father
and your in your your wives yes we're
both married so our wives are Muslim and
then hamdulillah Allah bless us with
children and insha'Allah you know we
build the family and that way as well
with our children and I also have two
cousins who accepted Islam you know
because of the interaction you know it's
a little bit difficult with them as well
they're kind of
you know and they have that surrounding
their young girls and they have the
surrounding is difficult growing up you
know nowadays we're in the city where
I'm from so a lot of Latinos are
accepting this a lot of Latinos are
accepting Islam especially in the areas
that that I'm in you know if the family
values are there even before Islam so it
kind of just enhances it yeah you know
it brings family closer together and it
gives us all reason you know again we
have a law we have God and kind of just
puts all the pieces together how about
for the boys the young men the old men
who are sitting there writing poems for
women's now they're sitting there and
they're figuring out man I got that's
all he's thinking about all days how is
he going to get Susie QZ Fatima and he's
making lies or even truths but now he's
gonna manipulate her in the wrong way
just to get what he wants then he's got
the black book and he puts her name in
there now when he's bored with a he goes
to be and it's a never-ending cycle of
destruction he's trying to get away from
it all so like when he thinks purpose of
life I'm not living it there's a void
but then he goes back to pornography he
goes back to you know drugs and alcohol
and he feels like you know I got to get
out of it but he's still in it what
advice do you have for him I mean in a
difficult situation I would definitely
you know even for myself you know take
it slow take it day-by-day but you know
if if God is involved and if Allah is
involved then you know as long as we
turn back to him and we worship Him and
we we build that relationship
Allah will make it easy but definitely
not go overboard and not think that from
one day to another everything's gonna
change
it is a progress it is something that
has to be done very slowly because if
not you know we may for even harder now
we may not like a certain thing and we
may go back to to even worse so day by
day take it easy and just try to do
things that you know we all feel things
that are correct you know hanging out
with family doing things that are good
and just try to busy ourselves with
things that are more positive than
trying to follow someone or trying to
follow TV or movies and things of that
nature
yeah the the reward of paradise did that
entice you knowing that look if I live a
good life this organic life that is
pleasing to the crater because God
doesn't need our work
of course some people have this false no
why should I worst yeah does he need
that he doesn't need it but we need it
because by worshiping God we remember
God we're more conscious of God we live
our purpose that we get to peace and God
wants the best from us so if we remember
God we're gonna become the best because
we're gonna be doing God's will not our
desires so the reward is paradise did
that motivate you thinking about man
paradise I can have anything beyond
imagination and a Hellfire that's the
reality
they have judgment I'm either going here
or there paradise and Hellfire that
motivates you to do good and stay away
from evil the the paradise the paradise
definitely motivates what motivated me
the most was the opposite end was the
Hellfire why because I was I knew that I
was doing things that were incorrect and
one of the major things was
disrespecting and disobeying my parents
and family which I know that that was a
no-no so that kind of you know knowing
that Hellfire is true
knowing the punishments of the Hellfire
knowing that I can end up there if I
continue this way that kind of you know
steered me in the right direction so
that was the motivation that I tried to
find myself and and still until today
you know try to keep those things in
mind you know that we're not free from
it we just have to keep on trying we had
to keep on worshipping Allah we have the
God we have to keep on you know being
this obeying our family our parents
being kind to people and doing things
that are good doing things that are
benefits ourselves our family and
everyone else around us being good doing
good for last minute that we have tell
the people tell me Spanish translated
English for those who are tuning in they
don't know much but they are enticed by
what we had to say about only worshiping
the Creator not his creation living a
good life how God wants us to live and
now the way of life that they were upon
they're like I don't want to worship a
man or a woman and this life is just
getting played out tell them in Spanish
what's the first thing they should do
what's the first thing you did explain
to them a little bit about Islam talk to
him please
in Spanish in English do both
simultaneously let's see if you could do
it juggle both just both definitely go
back into the religions of Catholicism
Christianity we all believe in one God
so go back to the to the
- Erica Cyril allah-allah case literally
Hill que solo and a career intend there
que solo indios and just basically you
know stuff from there just believe in
that believe there's only one one
creator and then everything else will
fall into place and then branch off into
believing that the prophets that he sent
prophets and messengers to to guide us
to help us to aid us in having a better
lifestyle and to living a
straightforward lifestyle and for the
translation purpose but a canadian los
mensajes was preferred us again knows
giving year oh my god knows you know
being uncle massages but are you that
knows anglers are either yeah so go back
to what's common between us a go back to
tommy was becoming between us and you
that you worship none but the crater and
don't set up a partner next to him and
in many of these books that been changed
over time you still see the peer
monotheism of not worshipping the
creation but worshiping the one god and
when people start to call upon the one
god and seeing that his message was set
through the messengers right yes that
they'll come to know that men jesus was
a messenger and he taught about another
messenger coming after prophet muhammad
peace be upon him and then they'll do
what you did and over 1.5 million
they'll testified that there's nothing
where they worship except the one God
and Muhammad is the last and final
messenger and then they'll accept Jesus
is Allah is one of the messengers along
with Abraham Moses and that's what makes
them Muslim isn't it yes so just tell
them one time repeat after me
there's nothing worthy of worship but
the creator of the heavens and earth
there's nothing worthy of worship but
the heavens are the creative advantage
give it to him in Spanish no England
Dios except Allah kasemir si él no está
la nación yo Sara's oracion s worship
the Creator I love saying is worship the
creator and not his creation tenemos que
la voix de Dios
the AUSA Allah in NOLA Kardashian maybe
we've got some people in Spanish now
waiting at the lines they can call us
anytime 1-866 to Islam Spanish
despairing Gemara une autre cientos
1-800 who know juicy enters 662 say say
is does Islam Islam
you also have a you're the president of
company a design company working people
go to I got it like this call cool shirt
says I am Muslim awesome yeah we we do
graphic design and printing and we kind
of branched into doing some apparel for
the youth we had we saw t-shirts from
the rapper's and you know the mainstream
they have all these messages messages
that have curse words and have you know
these ill messages that we didn't feel
especially the Muslim youth it was the
right direction for them to go to so we
try to create something with a little
bit more purpose a little bit more
meaning and as a form of calling other
people to Islam some of our messages on
our shirts actually intrigue the
non-muslims they ask questions kind of
opens the doors makes it easy you know
get in through the fashion aspect of it
and so that's what we started to try to
help in this whole and changing of you
know the way the the youth and the
Muslims think may Allah reward you to
the creator of the heavens and reward
you thank you for being with us made
this program be a benefit to so many
people who are lost out there in a
jungle of confusion and inshallah they
call upon the Creator here in your story
calling upon the crater alone to guide
them like you did only God only the
Creator I said in Spanish solo solo
india's solo Nielsen on this how you say
goodbye in Spanish adios adios amigos
please be with you tonight and that's
another brothers story of how he came to
this beautiful way of life doesn't
matter if you're French or Chinese
african-american Latino this Russian
German Greek this way of life is for
everybody it's a way of life that brings
you peace happiness something that money
can't buy so turn to the owner of peace
the one who created you the one who took
care of you when you're in your mother's
womb the one who's providing you with
the air that you breathe the food that
you eat that's the one God the one who
created Jesus Moses Abraham and sent
them with a mission a mission to call
you to paradise to purpose and the last
and final messenger sent to mankind of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon all of
them they all came and taught and
brought the same message worship only
the Creator who created you not his
creation and obey the message that was
said call us operators are standing by
106
to Islam we don't need your money we
don't need your money we just need you
to really reflect and think why you've
been created here in his story I hope it
motivates you to do good to be good to
be upon this way that brings you
everything that money can't buy peace
prosperity and dis life paradise and the
next you want to avoid the Hellfire we
got one shot to get it right before
death overtakes us all then it's too
late
we'll see you next time visit us get the
new dunya to dean at this website here
at a DVD comm we'll see you next time
God willin peace be with you and if
we're gonna worship something I figured
I might as well worship the Creator
instead of any of the creations now in
upon investigating the villages I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who cemento submit to God God's
will die see Islam was pure it was just
you just pray so good you create
I am not afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid